i just got out of the shower that the
friends reunion is happening
the friend's reunion is happening the
friends reunion is happening
the friends reunion is happening if you
have flight plans on may 27th
get off the plane because the friends
reunion is happening where on hbo max
may 27th the french reunion is happening
the friends reunion gets an official
trailer so excited to check this out
obviously i am very excited my all-time
favorite show
all-time favorite show some people were
trying to downplay this like you know
it's
just a reunion of the cast getting
together it's not an actual
episode that they're they're filming
like i know but still like they haven't
been
on screen together all six of them for
like almost like 20 years or something
it's been a long time if you guys see
them together in like bloopers and
interviews
oh it's magical i love them they're the
best they're my friends are my real
friends
[Music]
hey guys so this video got hit with a
copyright claim and i've had a lot of
videos get hit with copyright claims as
of late
so if you'd like to watch the reaction
you can go to the description box or the
pin
comment watch the vimeo link and you can
come back here
and check out our thoughts on what we
had to say after watching the trailer
thank you guys
best thing in the world oh best thing in
the world right there i'm going to be
bawling
yeah i mean this looks super touching
and also super fun
i love that they're getting together to
do a table read of one of the classic
episodes of all time
maybe more than that but where they all
find out i remember having
like a growing up they didn't used to
sell seasons but what they
did before you were able to just get
access to seasons they had dvds of like
the best rated episodes of friends and
it was
right after season six came out i don't
think season seven had come out yet and
that was one of the episodes
and yeah that is a that is a brilliantly
written
episode and it is just so fun to see
them all back together you know like
david schweber
i i always associated that in the
interviews for friends he always looked
like the most
kind of serious one of the group but
here throughout this whole trailer that
you get at the reunion he looks just so
gleeful and excited nostalgia
all of them have that glimmer in their
eyes but david schwimmer i don't usually
associate that with him when it comes to
them all doing these like interviews and
stuff together he even looks really
happy to be here from every time they
talk about this even right down to
jennifer aniston who's become a
superstar
since this series air like she's gone
out to do movies and stuff but she even
talks about how much she misses this
show and how she really didn't want it
to
actually end and the vibe that you
always get from the cast
with all these shows you always feel
like they got to a point where they're
like okay it's time to say goodbye let's
let's end this but for all of them it
seemed like they just
never really wanted this series to
end because they really did have this
like bond and you've seen them
hang out together when they're not
filming there's not a crew you know like
they really are this
family i mean yeah it definitely carries
that vibe i mean you know you introduced
me to friends i haven't seen as much of
the show as you but it does seem
apparent like there are a lot of reasons
you could be cynical about something
like this but the
energy coming off of them seems really
authentic and also too like we were
talking off camera
you know over the past couple days you
know since you put up that sketch about
you know people bulking yeah
the idea that it's not like an episode
or something like that but this looks
like a multi-faceted
special it looks like yeah they're doing
some stuff in front of a live audience
but then they're doing some stuff to go
back to the old sets they're going to do
a table read they're going to do trivia
really making it look like a worthwhile
event that's going to be
fun as much as it is nostalgic you know
the trivia at the beginning
is off one of the most famous episodes
of all time and to be playing that game
again and having
uh david schwibber being the host of it
yes this has been for the fans
and i know they got this like crazy cast
list of special guests
lined up bts is even going to be there
because rm
rap monster said that he learned english
from watching friends growing up
speaking french
you're going to have all these other
guest stars of who
like richard you know tom selleck is
going to be there janice i saw this
going around and i
i do agree i wish paul rudd was part of
the guest list i'm hoping there was just
a scheduling conflict or something but
he was he's mike he's part of the final
episode he's phoebe's husband you know
so i think it would be really great if
you could actually get paul rudd to
appear in here somehow even if it's just
like a zoom or a video thing like he
couldn't make it
paul rudd needs to be there he does oh
is that cara delevingne in the
bridesmaids
oh it is outfit
oh how hilarious there got to be guests
and surprises too lined up so
maybe somebody like paul rugg could show
up in that capacity i mean there's a
whole lot of guests that they already
released like a
bunch of guests paul rezab one of them
and i love it in front of the fountain
there's not one episode
where they're in front of the fountain
other than the opening credits that
lasted all
through all 10 seasons you never
actually saw them interact in front of
this
fountain like half scenes and stuff
together so they have the reunion where
you're bringing the couch out there
you got the fan and the fountain there
it does feel like a full circle vibe
that they have
completely assembled here because yeah
guys when this show ended i was
devastated for like
i was seventh or eighth grade when the
show ended probably my first experience
to
having to say goodbye to someone that
you
like with that feeling when you have to
like whether you go through a heartbreak
or you have to say bye to someone who's
moving or whatever you leave an
emotional attachment yeah yeah that was
the
probably my first ever experience
with with uh feeling an attachment to
individuals like i know they're
fictional characters but you're a kid i
mean maybe as an adult i'd still feel
that way but as a kid they were my
escapism
like so much i wasn't really a social
guy and at home i wasn't really a social
kid i didn't really talk when going to
school
i adapted so much of the personalities
mainly from the guys
like chandler growing up and learning
like hearing that line about sense of
humor being
his like form of repression and then for
me as like a depressed kid i
i sort of just adopted that mentality of
like i'll find a way to be funny when
i'm in school that's what i mean like
this show really saved me in a lot of
ways like it was this show and conan
o'brien kind of this was slam bam of
both of them together that were like my
childhood
so yeah this is my favorite show of all
time and even going back and revisiting
it
there are some things in the show that
the comedy that's definitely outdated
where you're like
this would be problematic in any other
show today
but as it stands you know it's still
like it still holds up and they're still
so sharp what's great is like all six of
them are good there wasn't one weak
player they were all
it was like a band like they were like a
perfect band where
every single one of them really was the
star
of this show a lot of like even if you
had like the fresh prince for you you're
like you got will smith and everyone
else yeah
you know but like you got james avery
and then the guy plays carlton and then
everyone else you know
there's kind of an order of who the
stars are but friends
like no they were all equal how many
shows can you really say that about
yeah it's it's a very like i get why
this would be
such an event because they did capture
lightning in a bottle it really did
it's hard to find six stars to have
a whole nation the whole world endeared
to this way and to yeah create that
legacy where you have somebody like bts
who's like this taught me english
yeah you know and now we all get to play
the wonderful game of who is aged the
best
what'd you guys think of this trailer
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
hit that notification bell click that
like button last but not least
flev doran you become a great friend of
ours over at patreon you really have
been like every time i'm able to finally
catch up to one of your messages you're
always giving us such
rich layers of what's been going on with
your life or what's been capturing your
interest
as of late you have been unconditionally
supportive to us and understanding on
whatever delay or mistake we make
and it's nice to have someone like you
in our corner showing your support
so thank you so much for being here i
just want to give a sincere thank you to
you phleb because
you rock man and i always look forward
to seeing whatever you got to say
and you're always chiming in on our
comments too you're chiming a lot on our
patreon you are
becoming like one of our most vocal
supporters so
thank you so much for being you glad to
call you a friend dude